on a personal level a lot of urban
dwellers live this contradiction even if
they are not personally responsible for
displacing a family or a tenant from a
single room occupancy hotel but it's
true that we with our consumers tastes
are responsible for knocking out a lot
of the old and bringing in a lot of the
new also with the amount of rent or the
amount of money we can pay to buy an
apartment
we may be displacing people who don't
have that kind of money so the first
step is to be aware of the cultural
power that people have the second step
is to force local governments to make
policies and make laws to protect
people's right to stay in the apartments
or the houses that they have this is as
true of people whose mortgages are being
foreclosed as it is true of tenants
whose apartment complexes or tenant or
apartment houses have been bought by big
investment companies that thought they
were going to make a killing on these
places and raise the rent but are now
foreclosing on their mortgages there
have to be actions by the state zoning
laws protections encouragement for small
businesses and the longtime residents
don't forget people who have been in the
city for a couple of years are on the
way to becoming longtime residents
we all need a place we all need a place
to live right so we we have to do the
best we can
given our economic circumstances and our
need to be close to where we work we all
need to hunt and gather to provide for
ourselves and our families that means
that we all need stores and so it's
inevitable that we shape the built
environment around us there has to be
some interaction between people's needs
and urban spaces but what's what's
really crucial is that we try to even
the playing field for the people who
can't pay high rents the people who
don't get good public services and the
people who can't escape right because we
all live in the city together I think
what city dwellers really appreciate is
the diversity of the city and you can't
have diversity if everybody is a
college-educated gentrify ER